This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month in 30 days
for free. If you sign up through the link below and use the code biographics.
We're on them M a bit.
If you were asked to name the most important figure in modern Chinese history,
who would you pick the obvious answers chairman? Now,
the communist leader who ruled the middle kingdom with an iron fist for over 25
years, but there's another figure, at least as influential as Mau,
his name Chiang Kai-shek modern China's longest serving roulette.
Chiang Kai Shek started out as a low level revolutionary before rising to the
very top of the Kuomintang.
It was under his watch that China was reunified after his warlord era,
that the prosperity of the Nanjing decade was ushered in.
And that China took its place among the superpowers of the day.
It was also under Chiang. That's a brutal Japanese invasion took place.
The Mao's communists were allowed to gain and strengths,
and that the deliberate flooding of the yellow river killed up to a million
people, both the dictator and the Democrats, a Confucian and a Christian,
an icon and a monster. This is the life of Chiang Kai Shek.
The man who created modern China.
[Inaudible].
When Chiang Kai-shek was born on October the 31st, 1887,
it was into an empire that was on the verge of collapse.
The last century had been one of unparalleled catastrophe for China.
There had been zop and Wars European colonization.
The gigantic Taiping rebellion in short,
the writing was on the wall for the Imperial family in Beijing.
The Chinese parents could have had no way of knowing how he had helped dispose
of them, especially since the family were doing pretty well.
Chang's father owns a plantation that brought in 60 Mexican silver dollars a
year,
a huge sum by rural Chinese standards and just one of the many currencies and
use at that time, when he died in 1895,
the plantation passed to Chang making him comparatively wealthy. Yes,
there was still something rotten below the surface.
Something no one in China could then ignore its name was the Ching dynasty
rulers of China since 1644,
but as Chang would soon discover they wouldn't be around much longer in 1903.
The boy ran away from his village to join the army.
At the Belding military Academy, he came into contact with hundreds of Chinese,
from rural backgrounds, all openly and teaching.
By the time Chang left the Academy for Japan in 1907,
he was already a diehard Republican at this stage.
You might be wondering why on us.
The future presidents of China would head off to Japan given that the two
countries hated each other's guts, but that you can thank the Imperial army.
Just a couple of years earlier,
Japan had become the first Asian nation to beat a European power on the
battlefield.
When Russia lost the rustle Japanese war in 1905 for the Chinese who'd spent
half a century watching their country get kicked around by colonial dishes.
This had been an eyeopening moment.
Plenty of young men hightailed it to Tokyo to learn war from the experts among
them Chang.
Then that was how Chiang Kai-shek came to spend four years serving in Japan's
Imperial army.
There was while abroad that Jan completed his journey to republicanism.
He symbolically cut off his cue.
That long braid of hatching subjects were legally obliged to wear and act to
this marked him out as a revolutionary, sadly for Chang. He wouldn't be there.
When the revolution actually came in 1911,
a police raid on an underground bomb factory became the spark that ignited
China's sing high revolution by December.
Dozens of cities were an open revolt and a provisional governments had been set
up in Nanjing under soon. Yet sin over in Japan,
Chang had become something of a notorious womanizer keeping dozens of girls on
the go at any one time. Now he ditched them all.
Then hightailed it back to home.
We like to imagine while stuffing away his trouser snake, as he ran,
there was no way he was going to miss this.
Unfortunately that's more or less what happens in January, 1912, Ching general,
one Chicago talk to the Imperial family and to voluntarily giving up power on
February the 12th, the boy Umbra Poony abdicated ending the revolution only,
not quite within a year.
The general one in Chicago had killed China's fledgling democracy,
making himself military dictator.
Suddenly Chanco Shaq had a cause that he could actually fight for.
And he wouldn't let this opportunity go to waste.
One's dictatorship lost his myth three years,
but after three years of fighting Chiang,
Kai Shek lived to see the general deposed,
but rather than usher in a new era of peace and unicorns and rainbows one's
downfall instead ushered in the warlord era with one gone former Ching General's
role, like pretty much party time and started conquering, whatever they could.
There was always China shattering into warring provinces,
each headed by its own warlord. By now though,
Chiang Kai-shek had had enough presumably with a mustard, whatever,
dead the format,
revolutionary moved to Shanghai and joins the Ching bang famous gang of opium
traffickers. But this would be just a detour. The pause before his life story,
proper could begin down in China's South Sunni out sin was growing in strength.
In case you forgot him in the barrage of names we throw at you.
Someone was the guy who declared the provincial governments in Nanjing during
the revolution.
Now leader of the Kuomintang also known as the KMT or nationalist party.
He was also the country's most ambitious warlord,
Sonia Sen plans to reunite China.
It was a plan young Chanco shack could get on board with in 1918,
Jang joins the KMT soon rising up the ranks. He was so competent. Let's in 1923,
some trays them to go to the USSR to study Soviet tactics when Chang written and
it was with Soviet advisors who quickly set about whipping the KMD national
revolutionary army into shape. It was the start of a world changing movements.
It was in the new form that the Kanzi started admitting communists once that
mortal enemies, although some worried, this would empower the KMT is hard,
left it soon, turned out that underestimated Chung's cunning on March the 12th,
1925 sung out sene died of cancer,
but not before outlining a detailed plan for crushing the warlords reunifying
China and slowly implementing democracy.
Chanco shank was named as successor and spent the next year preparing a massive
campaign against the warlords. Then on the Eve of battle,
Chang pulled off a breathtakingly ballsy move.
The cans on CU saw the arrest of prominent communists and the exile of the KMT
Soviet advisors. It was a risky play.
One that could have sparked a civil war in the coning Tang,
but Chang had picked his moment perfectly with his upcoming Northern expedition.
The only chance to crush the warlords,
even the remaining communists stayed loyal.
It was a decision that deeply regret from 1926 to 1928,
Chung's Northern expedition toppled warlord after warlord by 1927,
it was so obvious that the KMT was going to unite China,
that Jan was able to do the communist [inaudible] on April the 12th KMD troops
in Shanghai,
joined forces with the chain bang to mass execute up to 5,000 communists.
It was the start of a wave of violence that left the hard left, broken,
and Chang in the ascendancy. Finally in late 1928, the KMT captured Beijing.
The last remaining warlords, they swore fealty against all odds.
Chiang Kai-shek had done it hit fulfilled his old mentor,
sending out sends plans,
heads North and reunify China under a single government now only needed to do
was finished the implementing democracy part and it'd be done.
And yeah, about that,
it turns out democracy wasn't particularly high on Chang's things.
I care about list in no time.
It's all the former revolutionary was going to become the very person.
The masses were ultimate against.
[Inaudible].
Even before taking Beijing,
the Cuming Tang had established a new capital that would give its names.
The coming year out then entering decade was a time of relative peace and
prosperity for China under Chang the Republic embarked on a modernization spree.
That's all things like expanded education opportunities,
industrial developments,
and massive road building for those who've lived through the warlord era and
[inaudible] half-ass dictatorship before that. And Mr seemed like a golden age,
but only compared to what had come before objectively.
The Nanjing decade was the sets by problems.
The first was the KMT vice-like grip on government.
When Sonia at Sam had envisioned a dictatorship,
the transitions do a democracy is proteges rural,
like we're good.
There was a secret police that arrested or assassinated dissidents among Chang's
generals. Corruption was rampant.
It probably didn't help that Chang had recently converted to Christianity and
married into the extremely wealthy song family for the dirt,
poor Buddhist peasants that made up 90% of China's population.
It must've seemed like the generalist Sumo was from another world,
but the real reason the Nanjing decade was doomed can be summed up in three
words, warlords communists,
Japan let's tackle the communists first,
despite Chang's 1927 purge the communists hadn't been wiped out that simply
retreated to that countryside base in Jang Xi province,
where they continued to plot revolution only now they were doing it against the
KMT. His parts Chang tried time and time again to wipe them out,
throwing armies that Chang she,
until we finally had the communists surrounds it in October of 1934,
but even this would go horribly wrong.
When the communists broke through the lines and spent the next year marching the
6,000 kilometers to the new base in Shang sheen known as the long March,
the narrow escape became the communist,
its foundational myth and inspired tens of thousands of people to join them.
It also led to the rise of the undisputed leader, chairman Mao,
but despite being indestructable the communists weren't China's biggest threat,
that would be James' old inspiration.
The Imperial army of Japan in September, 1931,
Tokyo used a false flag attack to invade an occupied Manchuria in China's
Northeast establishing a sadistic puppet state under the former boy emperor
[inaudible] yes,
even as Japan used mentioned area as a staging post for annexing,
more Chinese territory, Jang refused to stop focusing on the communist threat.
As the decades slipped by this became more and more nonsensical by 1935,
the Imperial army had annex parts of Hebei province and modern in Mongolia.
They were starting to encircle Beijing. Yet.
Chang had insisted on sending his troops chasing off after chairman. Now,
now this leads us neatly to the Nanjing decades, final fatal floor.
The warlords when the Northern expedition ended,
not all warlords had been defeated.
Some simply switched to nominal support of the KMT while maintaining their own
power bases.
One of these was [inaudible] in Cheyenne dude who felt China should really be
focusing on these Japanese invaders rather than worrying about a bunch of
commies.
So he just straight up kidnapped him taking place over the winter of 1936,
the Shan incidents was an Epic humiliation for Chang Jang held him prisoner for
two weeks until basically said, okay, you win.
I promise I'll stop fighting. Whereas now Jesus Christ,
all those yang would be arrested after freeing.
The generally Simo air was now too late for the game Dee to change its mind in
early 1937,
the Cuming tannins communists forms the second United front to counter any
further Japanese invasions. They sealed their packs just in time. Now,
just before we continue with today's video,
let me take a moment to thank today's sponsor, making it possible.
CuriosityStream CuriosityStream is a subscription streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers, including exclusive originals. Now,
if you're enjoying this one all about China,
then why not try out curiosity stream for free, by the way,
there's a link below and check out their series is a docu-series called curious
minds, China, which has seven episodes,
all about the emergence of China as a modern economic power.
And it looks at how it balances communism capitalism.
If you're enjoying this video and you'd like to step a few decades into the and
learn about where China ended up,
this is a great series to check out curiosity streams available on many
platforms. There's a web app, Roku, Android, Xbox one. Look,
if you've got some sort of screen that was built in the last few years,
you're going to be able to watch curiosity stream on there.
It's also available worldwide.
So there's no geo restrictions get unlimited access starting at just two 99 a
month for you guys. The first 30 days completely free.
If you sign up at curiosity,
stream.com forward slash biographics use the code biographics during the signup
process.
That is a great way to support this show that keeps us making sure more videos
it's a great fit. So yeah, link below and let's get back into it.
It came to China on the 7th of July, 1937,
that evening a skirmish with Japanese troops that the Marco polo bridge
snowballed into the second Sino-Japanese war. It was like opening a flood gate.
The Imperial army swept across China, capturing Beijing, Tianjin,
Shanghai and Nanjing come January, 1938.
The governments had been forced to move the capital to Wu Han,
but even that was under threat.
Although the KMT had the communists and warlords on side.
Now this was just extra Canon Volta for a well-oiled fighting machine,
like the Imperial army.
It was sort of like trying to take down Gingiss Khan by teaming up with the
mighty ducks by some in 1938,
Japanese bombers were devastating cities as the army closed in on UConn,
it was in the face of this threat.
Chiang Kai-shek made his most controversial decision.
Yet the Imperial army was advancing across the yellow river flood plain swath of
lands where powerful floods occasionally washed away millions.
So why not flood it deliberately on June the ninth,
1938 KMT troops acting under Chang's orders blew up 17 kilometers
of, substituting water for soldiers. No warning was given to the civilians.
When the dynamite went off, the river came surging out drowning.
The country's heart today it's estimated that 890,000 people died
in the 1938 yellow river flood and maybe another 3 million and the subsequent
Fran and almost all of them, Chinese peasants, nor did the waters slow.
The Japanese. In fact,
breaching the was so useless that Jan blamed it on Tokyo and the way he gives
the failed flood, Jang retreated again,
establishing a new wartime capital in Chung, Ching. And once there he did well,
absolutely nothing.
It's common to criticize Chang's actions in this part of the war when his entire
strategy revolved around waiting for the U S to save as,
but let's what else could he do?
There was no way the KMT even with the communists would be able to defeat
Imperial Japan.
That's a just keep your head down and wait for Tokyo to slip up and slip up.
They did the Japanese advance had been so Swift and China,
so vast that Tokyo found itself unable to police behind its own lines.
This allowed communist partisans and warlord armies to attack and destroy
Japanese supplies almost at will.
It should have been a fatal mistake for the Imperial army. Unfortunately,
Jack was having problems of his own as the 19 dawns,
the Chongjin governments plummeted in popularity. There was inflation shortages,
ramping corruption in the KMT,
even as it taxed the living crap out of everyone else. Oh,
and that whole thing about chairman Mao working with Jang turns out both leaders
had been crossing their fingers behind their backs as the war raged around them,
the KMT and communists clashed each blaming the other F at the mounting death
toll. And in fact, China split into three nations,
nationalist China in the West,
communist China in the North and Japanese China in the East.
It was an impossible state of affairs.
One that demanded a clear winner to unify the fractured land for a long time.
It looked like the winner would be Chiang Kai Shek on December the seventh,
1941, the Japanese committed a gargantuan bulls up by attacking Pearl Harbor.
As America came crashing into world war two China's position was elevated from
desperate underdog to one of the big four allies placing Chang alongside
FDR Churchill and Stalin. Great as this was though,
it wouldn't be until 1944,
that Japan was weak enough for the us to actually start supplying China with
material help even then with American guys flooding in Chang,
still committed some terrible mistakes,
terrified as generals might try to overthrow,
and he deliberately kept vulnerable supplies back from his own army.
By this stage, though, no amount of mistakes could slow Japan's collapse.
In 1945,
Tokyo pulls back from China to concentrate on defending the homelands into this
power vacuum swept Mao's communists liberated city after city in the East,
leaving the KMT scrambling for a propaganda when it was the start of a complete
breakdown between the two armies,
the ends of what will remain of the United front in no time at all,
China was going to transition from a catastrophic deadly war with a foreign
power to a catastrophic, the deadly civil.
Yes.
You were an ordinary Chinese peasant in 1945.
You might have not unreasonably been thinking something along the lines of well,
hooray peace at last,
but no sooner had Japan surrendered than the Chinese civil war was revving right
back off. So that credits both Chang and Maui tried to negotiate a peace deal.
But although they announced a framework for talks on October the 10th by then
war was already underway.
And so we come to the single most damning facts in the life of Chiang Kai
Shek. He should have won the civil war.
When negotiations broke down in 1946, the KMT seemed poised for victory.
They had more troops, more areas under their control, better equipments,
at least partial American backing that fool his KMT troops lead sieged,
communist cities,
Jang oversaw the opening of a new national assembly purged of all leftists.
Had you been betting on the outcome of the war?
You wouldn't have even considered now a long shot. So what the hell happens,
assemble answer hubris. All the KMZ were concentrating on taking the cities.
The communists were focusing on the countryside.
Remember how we said that 90% of China's population were peasants.
Well now certainly remembered.
And he knew it didn't matter how many Chang took so long as the communists out
the peasants on side, they would be unstoppable by 1947.
The tide had begun to turn that summer at us.
Fact-finding mission globally reported that now's victory was inevitable,
but it would take another year before Chang realized this simple and tragic fact
come 1948 KMD soldiers were defecting in droves to Mao's red army from holding
one 10th of Chinese territory at the outbreak of the civil war.
The communists now held onto a third on September,
the first day proclaims the North China people's governments. Meanwhile,
in nationalist territory,
Chang was having serious problems to cope with the costs of the war.
The KMT had started printing money and surprisingly,
this led to runaway inflation to counter Chang brought in harsh punishments for
economic crimes like hoarding. But by now,
corruption was so entrenched that KMT officials flouted the rules,
openly strikes, protests, and unrest paralyzed,
the cities and morale plummeted. Finally in late 1948,
Chiang was forced to swallow his pride.
He sent a message to Mau saying he wished to negotiate in Roseanne.
The chairman published a list of wanted war criminals with Chang's name at the
top that January, 1949 Janko Shaq resigned as president of China.
His successes desperately tried to come to terms with mal,
but by now the communists were unstoppable on April.
The 19th negotiations finally collapsed within five days.
The communists with marching on Nanjing,
the KMT dream of ruling China was over on June.
The second Jang was recalled and made ahead of the nationalist forces,
but his new role was simply to make sure that they all escaped alive as the
communists swept the last few pockets of resistance away,
Chang organized the evacuation of around 2 million nationalists to the Island of
Taiwan. On the 1st of October,
1949 chairman now declared victory in the civil war,
establishing the people's Republic of China barely two months later,
Chang and the rest of the nationalists evacuated the mainlands.
Their plan was to regroup on Taiwan and someday return, but they never did.
In any other video.
This might be the point where the story ends it's with Chanco Shaq,
watching the mainland received over the waters,
his dreams and tatters his reputation shot,
but not in this video because the life of Chiang Kai-shek still has one more
important chapter left to go.
It's time to watch the general generalist Simo turn from an abject failure and
to Taiwan's founding father.
Do you understand.
Taiwan became the KMD is the last holdout.
We have to go back to 1945 when Tokyo surrendered Taiwan had spent 50 years
as an Imperial possession, but rather than be returned to China,
it was handed solely to the KMT for local Taiwanese.
This kind of sucked the nationalists considered them Japanese collaborators
Chiang even appointed the racist Jen Yi as the Island's military governor and
allowed him to plunger its resources and to brutalize its natives.
Without restraints things reached ahead is on February the 27th, 1947.
When KMT agents beat an elderly woman in the street,
sparking a mass demonstration ended with several times when he's being shot,
dead known as the two to eight incidents.
It launched an Island wide uprising that Odie ended when Changs and didn't
troops and told them to let rip for an entire month Kanzi soldiers were allowed
to run rod across Taiwan. Civilians were machine gun for sports.
Women were raped and people were to capitated in the streets.
By the time order was restored up to 28,000 Taiwanese had been murdered
incredibly. This was just the start of KMT white terror.
Fast forward to May, 1949.
When chairman now is on the verge of victory ahead of evacuating to the islands,
Chang declared martial law in Taiwan,
effectively setting up a dictatorship while Chang's dictatorship would be way
less bloody than mows on the main lines.
It was still a pretty hideous affair lasting until July, 1987.
Martial law saw the kidnapping and murder of anyone who opposed the KMT regime
somewhere in the region of 3,500 were executed often on just fabricated
charges for democracy. This was not,
but no one was at a total disaster in the early days of Chang's rule.
It wasn't certain Taiwan would stay independence now toyed with taking the
islands and it was broadly assumes that he could do.
So if he wished to in Washington,
the state department even considered removing Chiang from power themselves,
but then things started to change.
The first was China getting involved in the Korean war,
which made the U S super keen on supporting Taiwan,
concluding a defense treaty with Taipei in 1955.
The second change was Taiwan's economic miracle realizing the SIM odds of his
regime,
survival Jang embarked on a modernization drive to transform the Island into a
base of manufacturing by focusing on fabrics and consumer electronics,
the KMT government kick-started and economic boom that saw Taiwan outstrip,
the dysfunctional mainland by the late 1950s,
Chiang was even working hard to root out corruption in the KMT and making sure
each of the islands ethnicities benefited from his rule.
If you sort of squinted and ignored the political executions and the lack of
democracy you could was convinced yourself his rule was benign. Yeah.
Chang would be cursed live long enough to see the winds change yet again in
1971, a vote at the UN. So all Taipei lose China's seat to Beijing.
The beginning of Taiwan's waning influence. Just one year later,
president Nixon made a surprise visit to mainland China,
turning the PRC from a pariah into a global player by the decades,
Zen countries would be breaking off diplomatic relations with Taipei in droves
to cozy up to Beijing. But by then, Chiang Kai-shek was no longer around. Well,
the fifth, 1975 Chang died of renal failure in Taiwan.
A month of mourning was declared slightly over a year later on September the
ninth, 1976, chairman Mao also passed away. And with that,
the two most important men in modern Chinese history, when I'm off today,
Chiang Kai-shek legacy remains controversial while it's tempting to hold him up
as a Saint compared to chairman Mao, being less of a colossal Dixon mows,
a dong is kind of a low bar to clear lest we forget the general
SMO was the man who killed millions flooding the LA river,
who deliberately starved the troops of rival generals of supplies during a
catastrophic war whose hubris led to mouse communists winning mainland China
in Taiwan to Chang's legacy is unsettled while plenty cm as a founding father,
plenty more seen as the who murdered thousands for the crime of wanting
democracy in shorts,
we can't claim he was much of a hero or even a great leader.
What Shankar shack was though was significant as the general,
who ended the warlord era oversaw the Nanjing decade,
stared China through a Japanese invasion and a civil war than founded modern
Taiwan. Chiang has an outsized impact on East Asian history,
perhaps more so than anyone else.
His story may be one of corruption and incompetence of dictatorship and death,
but it's also the story of a nobody who grabs the reigns of history and refuse
to let go for better or worse.
Our world today is still shaped by Chiang Kai-shek actions.
We can think of no greater compliment to give the general emo than that.
And I really hope you did enjoy that video. If you did,
please do hit that like button below.
Please do support this show by supporting one of our fantastic sponsors link
today's sponsor curiosity streaming.
There is a link below to thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].